when Rod Fergusson joined us on our III
stage our conversation covered a lot of
ground as a veteran of Epic Games and
founder of the coalition his insight is
key to understanding the evolution of
Gears of War it's also key to
understanding the newest entry in the
storied series the coalition became the
steward of the franchise when epic sold
gears to xbox game studios with that
came the weight of an eight-year legacy
one that Ferguson having worked on every
mainline Gears game to date didn't take
lightly as he sat on the e3 stage with
gears for the studio wanted to earn fans
trust with Gears 5 it wanted to evolve
and after spending a week with Gears 5
surrounding myself and all of its
changes and exploring every mode I can
safely say it has evolved in fact in
many ways it's taken the sharp turn and
I couldn't be happier here's fives
changes are pervasive that is they come
in ways both big and small on the larger
side of things is escape mode it stands
apart from campaign verses and horde
mode adding a new pillar to the Gears of
War trifecta Escape is less about
hopping from cover to cover as you take
your time clearing a room it's about
forward movement and quick
decision-making as you fight your way
out of a dying swarm hive these tenets
aren't completely absent from previous
Gears games but they were never the
focus escape mode adds a whole new layer
to the gears identity so - to the
campaigns to open worlds based on early
reviews these spaces are proving
divisive and I can see why here's wars
built on steady pacing through discrete
environments and contained set pieces on
paper explorable sand boxes should throw
that pacing off but in my experience
they don't in fact I found they did the
opposite they allow for some breathing
room a come down so to speak after the
high of a boss fight or the intensity of
a cutscene they allow characters to
interact away from the blood gore and
cursing of a gunfight they also
emphasize preparation and planning over
split-second reactions that is they
change how you compose your loadout
Delta squad's skiff can store two
additional weapons meaning you can
create a moving armoury fit for an array
of situations you can prepare for what
you think is going to be a long range
shootout only to find that it is in
act a close-quarters nightmare gears
creative Arsenal's have long been a
staple of the series and the open world
subtly change how you outfit your
characters well you could make the
argument that the Coalition is chasing
trends by adding open spaces to its
linear formula it does enough to make
them feel distinct it used them to
encourage planning and characterization
doing away with the fire fight cutscene
fire fight formula its relied on for so
long
although the coalition runs the risk of
alienating many fans with these
sandboxes it's refreshing to see them
reexamining what makes this series tick
as I mentioned earlier there are changes
on a smaller scale as well
tons of them and while they seem subtle
in isolation they all combine to create
a much different combat flow than I've
experienced in Gears fives predecessors
these range from basic stealth to a
deeper melee system Gears 5 also does
away with the reticle bloom of earlier
installments opting instead for actual
weapon recoil in essence they've changed
how it feels to play a Gears game
traditional wisdom says not to fix what
isn't broken but this is the rare
exception what's more Gears 5 implements
a companion character that rivaled the
likes of at Reyes in God of War by
upgrading your squad's robot aka the
ever loveable Jack he allows you to
cloak around enemies opening them to
brutal finishing attacks he can freeze
opponents where they stand shortly
before your squad shatters them from
cover he can even fetch you ammo items
and weapons and trust me when I say that
this ability is his most useful by far
the result of these minor tweaks is that
I'm actually spending more time out of
cover than ever before considering Gears
defined the cover based shooter and
built a legacy on it to boot it's
strange to be out in the open sending a
robot to stun someone while I sprint up
with a cloak on and execute them from
behind even on harder difficulties Gears
5 encourages me to be creative with my
approach and it's rewarding every step
of the way
there are numerous other changes the
Coalition has introduced to its namesake
franchise but all of this is to say that
despite how divisive some of them will
undoubtedly be it's promising to see a
studio attempting to change things the
Coalition will always be wrestling with
the past in one way or another Gears of
War 4 is safe approach is
proof of that but it feels like the
studio has finally hit its stride gears
5 feels like the developer had an
absolute blast
making it and for me that fun is
infectious I can only hope the coalition
continues to be so bold
you